thank you thank you uh hi my name is
Tamara chambers and this is Tamara's
never seen tonight I am finally watching
the horror classic the emotion movie
just kidding I'm singing Carrie I've
seen the movie Tamara which is in my
mind a Carrie esque film it's about a
beautiful high school girl who gets
bullied and then she dies and then she
comes back and kills everybody I know
that's not the plot of Carrie but in my
mind it was similar enough I was like I
don't even see Carrie I mean it's the
same exact thing I don't know if it's
good or bad I don't know if it's Carrie
or just suspenseful I just know that she
gets covered in blood at some point and
so shall I sorry if my audio is bad my
microphone for my camera ran out of
batteries I don't know how to take the
lift thing off before the battery pack
can't figure it out you guys I'm blondes
do you get it a dumb blonde okay
moving up I'm excited to watch something
that's like it old a classic so let's do
it
towba first Tamra's never seen tagline I
was wrong no no Tamra you have heard a
lot about this movie don't believe this
out others it's your the story was so
much different than I thought it was
going to be in my mind
Carrie was always this beautiful
stunning high schooler who's just like a
little awkward and she's getting bullied
but Leon is unbelievable and you know I
don't think I'll sympathize with this
character really which is what a bitchy
thing to say Tamra but honestly I loved
her she was so good at being she's
clearly beautiful but she's really good
at being a tormented teenager who has a
batshit crazy mom who has been raised in
this
mr. religion who has never had a dad who
had all these things have led up to her
being who she is it she's just such a
good job with the acting I just I love
her is she in anything else ah do you
open I'm Carrie in high school they're
in PE class and Carrie misses a shot for
a volleyball game they're playing in PE
and all the girls are livid they're
pissed and they're making fun of her
there hit her in the face and that's the
most unrealistic part of this entire
film is how seriously these young women
are taking a volleyball game that they
played in PE because thinking back on
high school there's nothing that I cared
less about venti then I just wrote whoa
locker room boobs then after I thought
about it a little bit more I realized
that these were all high school women
and you're just getting a very long
drawn-out kind of like never a new story
ask misty mystical scene I'm just a lot
of women's boobs and bushes and bodies
and then Kerry's taking a shower just
like oh my god it's a porno we're just
I'm just gonna lather it's weird it was
shot in a beautiful way that like I
think you're supposed to be into it I'm
saying Mike you know what I mean so
while lathering herself up in a porno
fashion Carrie starts her period for the
first time ever and she freaks out and
listen I get it once a month are you
kidding me disgusting no thank you
what a bummer the woman's body can be a
ravenous House scape that no one can rid
up but this wasn't just a damn that
sucks this was a hysterical Helene this
crazy freak out and you find out that
she's freaking out because she has never
heard of a period before and is because
her mom is so religious I
take to you this word I know a lot of
people online don't love this word it's
very triggering that someone who grew up
and not like a lot of like extreme
religious nish it puts very like up I
get it I see I understand I get all of
this happening to a lesser extent
I was never locked in a closet no sure
oh poor carry three words and that
should be the tagline of the film Carrie
oh poor Carrie but did you see her
dealing with her mom you see her dealing
with bullies in school you also see her
dealing with these telekinetic powers
that she has she flipped an ashtray in
the principal's office and she flips
this boy off of his bike when he's like
scary hairy scary hairy and she breaks a
mirror in her room when she's sad that
her mom is like hitting her and it's all
pretty relaxed at this point I know that
the movie is gonna go to the extreme
I've seen the blood photo before but if
this with me I would just be like
bitches and die y'all can go to hell by
really the only person this is like
behind her and all of this is the PE
teacher who saw the sad period scene in
the very beginning where they threw a
bunch of tampons of Pat's at her so
funny high school girls are very
creative hilarious but the PE teacher
rules she's trying to encourage her to
come out of her shell I know she slaps a
girl in the face and that's not
technically cool but whatever shoot
rules so I wrote down oh my god John
Travolta is in this and
Oh No he slapped the popular girl again
she gets not a lot in this film
nice popular girl is feeling very shitty
at this point and she tells her crush to
ask Harry to the prom and it's really
cute and he's like oh I'll do it and
they're very a wholehearted and very
sweet and just good sports about it and
he's like no yeah sure for sure I mean
it's kind of weird but ya know it's like
so kind and you just root for him the
whole time at the prom he's kind of like
falling for Carrie
the prom is great she's so happy so
sweet I already feel so bad because I
know it's coming Carrie and Tommy win
prom king and queen I knew it was coming
but I was still really sad about it
happening and I didn't want it to ruin
her prom I knew her prom is gonna be
ruined but I didn't want it to be ruined
and so I was like you know whatever
it won't happen everything's fine
popular evil girl and John Travolta are
under the stage drinking beer and I
think that John Travolta is just always
under a high school auditorium stage
drinking beer and then somebody's like
hey you have a Rowling's at kuku cool
here I come what is he doing his off
time the holes holes you really happy
bird she what prom queen everyone's like
oh why have we been such a dick this is
so cool what a triumphant
story they spend like five minutes with
her on stage just being very happy and
crying just like thank you oh my god I
can't believe this is happening over
five minutes
[Music]
right before she left at the prom her
mom was like everyone's gonna laugh for
you everyone's gonna laugh at you and
she chokes up everyone's really nice to
her except for John Travolta and Chris
the popular bitch and so when that
happens she hears her mother's words in
her mind and then she kills everyone she
kills Tommy the guy that was really nice
to her and kissed her and she cools the
PE teacher which is like greatest ally
the popular girl Chris and John Travolta
drive towards her as she walks down the
street like they're gonna murder her and
I know she has killed an auditorium full
of high school students but that's a
little extreme
I am still team Kerry team Kerry
everyone of course she kills them top us
their car over telekinesis that's how it
works
she goes home and her mom has this crazy
episode she stabs Kerry and then Kerry
full-on just telekinesis stabbed her mom
with a bunch of knives my favorite part
of this is that the Jesus statue that
she's been praying to this whole time
has a very specific stabbing pattern and
she stabs her mom in the same exact
pattern I think that's awesome the house
spontaneously combusts and then falls
into the earth unfortunately she dives
into her mother's arms
Wow the house goes into the ground and I
know that her mom was all that she had
her mom was also terrible and it's a
really sad fate for her I wrote not
scary but really well done and truly
horrifying this was so psychological it
was so well developed character wise
next week I'm putting out a video of
Doug Walker on the first an original
Texas Chainsaw Massacre
that we're doing the human centipede
which hilarious okay as I have a video
coming out this week on my personal
channel about this cosplay and a lot of
fun octo
so check that out if you're interested
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you all next week back it's edible to
you doesn't mean it doesn't taste good
[Music]
[Applause]
you